foreign
activists are trying to face property
and artwork specifically because it is
shocking I don't know about you but I
saw the video of them throwing the soup
on Van Gogh and I immediately cringed it
it hurt to see and I think that's what
they're going for my name is Danielle
butcher I am the Executive Vice
President of the American conservation
Coalition which is a right of Center
non-profit organization that was founded
to give conservatives a voice on the
environment I am begging them to stop
using these tactics you cannot annoy
people into agreeing with you and
certainly throwing mashed potatoes or
glue or soup or dumping milk on a
grocery store floor those are not ways
that you convince people you are in the
right position and it's actually a
position of privilege to be in where you
can do these types of protests and
expect no repercussions for you or for
your cause people are talking more about
climate change in the aftermath of these
demonstrations in these stunts but the
context matters right when somebody is
in a grocery store and they see milk
being dumped out everywhere or they're
at a museum trying to admire Van Gogh
and suddenly there's like mashed
potatoes or soup thrown on it they're
not going home and talking to their kids
and talking to their spouse and saying
wow that was really insightful I'm gonna
sign up I'm gonna go advocate for what
it is that they're advocating for more
than anything it's an inconvenience or
it's appalling and people are shocked by
it they're not talking about these
things in a good context where they want
to link arms and join up and you know
advocate for the cause they are really
put off by it and I think that if you
are fighting for something it would be
in your best interest to build allies
it's not based in reality to ban fossil
fuels overnight and in fact if we did so
if we banned oil overnight emissions
would increase because we would be
burning coal or if we were to stop uh
Drilling in the United States then that
oil in that natural gas would still come
from places like Russia who have even
fewer environmental standards we do it
the most cleanly in the United States we
do it cleanly efficiently it's not
realistic to ban fossil fuels overnight
and in doing so we would actually harm
the environment more I do think that
marches or demonstrations with speakers
things like that with the signs that
that can be effective enough you know
but what I'm finding overall is that
these tactics are steeped in hypocrisy
so if you are seeing a March like that
oftentimes you'll see tons and tons of
litter and garbage Left Behind or if
people are blocking traffic then those
cars are sitting in traffic and they're
idling and they're emitting more
emissions than they would have if you
had just let those people be on their
way and get to their destination on time
and so the tactics again they're focused
on sparking conversation whatever that
means but they're not actually helping
the environment tangibly